up till now in our panel discussion on
ethnicity and conflict we've talked
about the innate psychological roots of
ethnic conflict the possible impact of
economics and the whole question of
whether multicultural programs actually
were in stemming ethnic conflict in this
last segment we asked our panelists to
talk about some of the possible
solutions that might arise out of human
conflict research you asked a
psychologist and as such I will give you
something that could be ratcheted up to
be a policy based on what I know to be a
signature result from from my own
discipline at my own work and and that
is the signature result is that there is
a dissociation or a disparity between
what we consciously about our values our
intentions and so on and then what we
implicitly or less consciously reveal
people how we eat our lives every day
there is a large disparity our values
are highfalutin our behaviors are
loading and that disparity I think if
that is made known to people if
individual people who can come face to
face with this disparity and then be
left to device for themselves a personal
policy it's athis I'm not talking about
the intervention of governments I'm now
just saying put the data in the hands of
the people show them that their own
lives are being led in such a way that
their behavior is not consistent with
their own values not that of a god not
that of their president not that of
their parents but themselves and once
you do that and do it convincingly I
have great hope that people will change
their behavior so that it's more in line
with their vows so that's an individual
approach mothering that you're
suggesting richer do you have any other
policy approaches that you might suggest
and then Debraj I'm going to ask you
that it's the same thing absolutely and
I mean my mártira decade modern and that
it's about not just telling people to
embrace diversity because
it's the right thing to do they're
telling me to embrace diversity because
it's beautiful them to do that and they
were stretching out which is showing
that people who do have multi cultural
experiences of living diverse
environments I'm showing benefits for
other aspects of their constant
functioning and so in confessor of
creativity problem solving various for
all the dimensions of cognitive
flexibility and so showing people with
evidence showing people that it actually
does you could not just because the
ambience then followed you bite and the
right thing to do but also good for you
as an individual is is the way to
achieve social change in this area de
Paris did you have anything you want to
add on this I can protect individuals
that I'm wondering if you have said
about a broader view for the des into
actual policy yeah quick caveat though
because i think that the stuff that you
guys are talking about fascinating and I
and I would not like to learn much more
about that no but I'm going to talk
about the economics of the policy that
doesn't mean that I think economic
motivations are fundamental and all of
this but i'm just going to provide that
as a separate perspective so so you know
the case of conflict one of the most
important things about real conflict
that we see in developing countries or
not i'm not trivializing a lot of what
you're talking about which are the
difference in attitudes and but
particular these are at best debates and
shouting at each other over pick a
dragnet off but people believe in
situations like that people actually
have to put their lives on the line
right so now very think about what
putting your lives on the line entails
it's that the alternative for young men
who are actually going there and
committing acts of violence is a life
generally of poverty unemployment there
other options are very limited so I
think to me it seems that the first and
most fundamental policy in vacation to
think about reducing violence as we see
one
this rapid economic growth now having
said that we just talked about examples
in which economic growth can actually
give rise to more violence but we talked
about the example of a Muslim it comes
going up and then actually inciting more
violence so it's not a very simple it's
not enticing for how how one is actually
to think about economic growth as as as
a violence reducer but there's no doubt
in my mind that sustained economic
development has to bring conflict down
simply because for people like you and
me is way too expensive to give up our
job and try and go out that kills of
people that's very okay so that's that
that would be my first college
application which is that focus on the
economics of development of the second
one would be information so let me give
you an example again I go back to India
which is better come from if you know
the effort if you think affirmative
action in the United States is quite
strong you should go to India okay India
has all sorts of the formatted action
there's so much affirmative action you
India that that the total of the reserve
I adds up to two more than a summons so
the so these guys a social so what
happens is why is the amount of action
is based on caste lines or or or Nam and
India even this call for religious lines
why is so much affirmative action case
of measles the reason is that is
impossible to get economic information
about how much a person bonds so the
Indian government would love to help the
poor okay let's assume it would love to
have before it comes out the phone
because we can't identify for the
forearm way to do at least you get a sum
has broadly correlated basic people or
low-cost window or actually shed Yukon
what up on check your cousin India and
then try to use policies that are based
on cars rather than based on economic
information because we don't happen
whenever the government receives
policies that are based on things like
cars it's absolutely fertile ground for
then creating salience along those lines
okay so it propagates simians so my
second point would be that we need to
build information by we I mean
government's need to use economic
characteristics in order to make
distributions of resources and cross
different groups and not use not
eternally conferences not that the
government is going to publicity it's
just that it has no other way to
actually carry out these fetuses you're
saying that same Lance means people
paying more attention to these cats
differences and that can be bad because
that can exacerbate a good diet I guess
what I'm actually okay I'm very I've
been right at the last and the last
policy point that I would make is what I
thought the best ability which has to do
it you know if you look at different
political groups the more contestability
there isn't political arena IV I use the
word the testability rather democracy
because democracy is a special case of
the disability what I mean more
generally is that each political group
in our country has somebody else waiting
in the wings ready to grab power and so
just the opposite of a dictatorship and
democracy would be a special case of
that once we have lots of the
testability then no proof can be ignored
or no group can be attacked without
serious worry about your own survival as
a political party so we see that in any
situation where there's a lot of
political contestability minority groups
activity protect minority groups are
protected not because of the benevolence
of the government but because of the
government's need to survive so I will
sisters summarize eternally pro
information for testability so kind of a
mixture of overhearing of large-scale
policy initiatives and and some very
individual individually focused things
it's been a fascinating discussion I
wanted to just give everybody an
opportunity for one last one
us comment if you if your of interest
there if you're interested in giving one
maza ring um I think that Professor a
will agree with me when I'd say that I
to come from India it's interesting to
me that on this panel you have two
Indians and a Brit I need a clean it
gives it yeah very nicely diverse I
think I actually I wanted to just say
that you know when you look at what
where India is today there is I think
absolutely no way it could be where it
is if the government had not had the
kind of the affirmative policy that it
has had the last 60 odd years the school
that I went to the college that I went
to it may have been an unusual one but
to admit students it took into account
test scores and you know letters of
recommendation and essays and exams and
then to that it added a set of
dimensions he'd your family live in a
part of the country that had famines in
the last X number of years had droughts
in the elastics number of years how much
money did your grandparents Nate you
apparently I mean this was this is the
kind of information that he's talked
with this was all gathered put into a
pool and then your admission would
determine by how you came out looking at
everything your own performance on the
standardized kinds of tests and essays
but also these very deep economic
challenges that some people may have
faced over others and and I think in the
US o people would be absolutely stunt to
think that anybody could ever use a set
of these variables and making decisions
like we should go to college but just
think about what that country is
achieved and I think that when you ask
what policy I think we should look at
the countries that have done things that
may seem rather than and just look at
the difference between where they were
in 1940s
that now and I think it tells you what
the right things are that we could be
doing Devraj sure no I i would say much
just to follow up on what what what
muttering just said because i think it's
very important the things that are
coming achieved because of us a call to
action are incredible but at the same
time these things also raise salience
and awareness along lines that that we
would not like to we would like to raise
say you know awareness about so how do
we how do we help me manage to reconcile
these points of view and that's what I
meant by information with you reconcile
is that we can direct information about
what people are or what their parents
have are so that we can use that
information just somebody's economic
deprivation alone to carry out our
affirmative action and it's only when we
do that that a lot of these semi
artificially created cast boundaries and
religious boundaries favorite yeah and I
just want to add that I actually think
that that's the way to persuade people
about it I think we will not be
persuaded and why should we be persuaded
when we are told that a brutal people
that were discriminated against in the
past are the ones that now should have
priority well I didn't do that I didn't
do that I need that thing you know 300
years ago or 200 years but why should I
pay a price today for that but I think
many more people will come along if they
know that we're not looking at racial
lines for affirmative action but rather
we're looking at economic lines there's
a floor affirmative action I think it's
a much more persuasive argument and will
will get traction and we use that rather
than of the ethnic and racial lines that
we tend to break up in this country
course those will come along with with
the economic ones that I do think that
the economic ones are very positive way
to frame the manner in which we want to
go about equalizing the society and
Richard crisp any any follow-up on this
block if what's been fascinating about
discussions is illustrated I think we'd
avoid the grid or degree which shows
that the cause of the conflict are are
multifaceted
may involve economic political social
and psychological financials and I guess
the take a message for me would be the
solutions also require social economic
political and many other dimensions to
the to it to address address human
conflict
you